Hey hello buddy welcome Betty who are
you we just had more I think now they
keeping you and Marc separated yeah we
don't speak good good we want it to be
healthy
no I'm obsessed with Marc Maron I am at
arm's length for the first couple
episodes of the first season so I was
like who is this guy is this a crabby
pirate of a man right do I need this in
my life just based on the aesthetic yeah
right in that he's a crappy pirate man
right okay but now I tell him I love him
every day that's so nice what changed
yeah uh I guess yes he's a crabby pirate
but he's also like boy
who's mad about having a splinter on the
day of his Bar Mitzvah like he's also
like right the vulnerability full of
exactly yes she's very vulnerable as
well and sometimes knowing somebody as
crabby is okay if they treat you well
like a lot of my friends are creeps to
other people yes but they're good to me
yes and I am also crabby like we share
the gene of like being on a porch
shelling peas judging people who walk by
right that's 85 year old it's just like
so we're we we do well together that's
good yeah
sit there making judgments about people
yeah and our set is a very energetic
you know Disney songs at 5:00 a.m. set
and you know sometimes I'm in the mood
for that and sometimes I'm I'm sitting
with marketing business too much who's
singing Disney songs the 15 women in the
cast what songs you singing you know I
mean like a whole new world type Disney
song world boys a part of the show or
they just no no no no it's like people
are professionals are setting up the
shot and they're like a whole new yeah
why are they singing I don't understand
no I don't either
I know it's it's just a lot of energy
right it's never like hey good morning
hey I'll see you later it's very like
good morning yeah and your vibe is more
like a that's a good morning like yeah I
mean sometimes sometimes I'm singing but
we're also you know dressed like insane
people right it would be maybe if
we were playing like Stern detectives in
Seattle we wouldn't be singing but our
hair is a foot high
we're in spandex we're covered in
glitter it kind of lends itself to
acting like an insane person I see yeah
I guess so
do you like doing media and press or do
you some actors hate it and some people
love doing it um I I like kind of
long-form stuff like this when it has to
be like soundbite ii like quick put your
personality in two sentences and pose
and wink especially as an actress like a
lot has to do with like lip gloss
squinty filtery stuff and that that
makes me a little nervous but I like
talking I'm definitely not one of those
actresses who pretends like I was woken
up in the middle of the night and forced
to be an act these are fun like I like
just having a conversation - were just
talking I'm just chatting bragging I
mean I'm really good at but no like some
people hate I hate short form
seven-minute things - that's terrible
yeah I was thinking about that I was
watching like an interview you guys did
for one of the morning shows I think it
was for season one but it was you and
Allison and Mark and you had four
minutes and there were three hosts with
you yeah and you're just like why am I
here and how do I do this yeah it's
scary it's scary and Allie and Mark have
done this kind of thing much longer than
I have so I definitely in those
situations I'm like oh I'll just be
quiet sometimes you'll just throw me a
question I'm like uh I was born like I
don't know how to write condense it you
just make sounds yeah give you an
interview and you realize I'm talking
way too much yes this is a long answer
for a short question yeah talking about
New Jersey nobody gives a [ __ ] why am I
doing this
yes yeah where you get ideas that are
insane like there's a representative in
your brain like typing out the sentences
that you're saying and then other people
in your brain are like handing them
since you're like what why would I ever
say that would be they would end my
career and now it's the only thing I can
think yes yeah no I was replaying my
yeah what yeah and you're trying to
squeeze it in without actually saying
yeah it's very difficult sometimes to do
a short one where you have one or two
things you have to say and you're
talking with other people you know
feels like they're being really
interesting and I'm not being
interesting it's yeah I hate that yeah
yeah it's weird but I thankfully I love
both of them so much so it kind of feels
like a coalition of I I don't know how
and I also love talking about the show
and I love the things that the show
stands for I can't imagine if it was
like you know Alaska space hospital like
if it was the sort of thing where I had
to be like now more than ever
Alaska so I thankfully am passionate
about the show what are you gonna do or
do you think about this or have you been
on sets before when you leave glow when
it's done yeah and you're done singing
and everything you get to your next gig
or whatever it is and because I would
imagine that most series don't start
with Disney songs and hello everybody
and we love each other but yeah but
there's tension now it kind of feels
like sometimes you know we have female
show runners and it's the cast of 15
women and Mark and it can sort of feel
like we're this like futuristic feminist
Montessori biodome I see and then you
leave and you're like this is the whole
world now and then I'm back to sort of
auditioning for tits on wheels with no
line do you have to call the character
[Laughter]
yes no but I do think things are slowly
changing I think especially now that
it's like the Salem witch trials of
being whoa like people are even even the
bro yes bros are like we love glorious
Dinah have you not even overt act but
just have you sensing or that guy's
[ __ ] like are their creepy things
that are happening to actresses that
most guys wouldn't notice if because
we're not in that situation yeah of
course yes I mean I think that is the
the biggest surprise of all of this for
me is the surprise of my male friends
like that happens like it's you
yeah it's like a toll but you have to
pay having a the feeling of a meaty bro
paw on the small of your back like
parent is I oh you know what by the way
what am I feeling of success yeah my
exes told me about that she's like I
[ __ ] hate cuz she's really hates men
and she really does [ __ ] hate when
men touch me and I never forgot that she
said that she think they guide you back
and I watch at the gym sometimes it's
fun to watch a trainer doing all this
weird touching I'm like I guess that
would be annoying
I never even never occurred to me well
you know the second it doesn't happen to
you it's not just a trainer being a
trainer right exactly
I tried to get her to touch me there's
something in the small of my back that I
don't hear guide nope it's a lump and
it's always guys that look like it's
never George Clooney looking man it's
always guys that look like eagle
abortions when you're like this you're
you look like Santa's brother who did
heroin like what you're hitting on me
right now just say RT does that does
that make a does that make a difference
if the guy not again not I mean overt
thing but like little moments like that
it doesn't help if a guy looks like
George Clooney at all no no a creep is a
creep that's a creep is a creep but I
think also creeps so often look like
creeps because they didn't get laid in
high school they could never rely on
their looks or personality so they get
into these positions of power and then
that's what they do they have our
editors and they they're using you to
audition there it's like the memoir
version of themselves when their real
life is that they're sad in a basement
farting into their cashmere pajamas
while their wife yells at them right
they're like I'm gonna like flirt with
you at crafty and make you feel small
and sad and that's gonna make me feel
good today so you think they're being
kind of whoo that's who they see
themselves they want to be because
you're on set and they're in a position
of power like all I can behave this way
with you but I can't do this stuff at
home yeah maybe I don't know I can't
pretend to know what a bro Co path feels
but yeah they're super disgusting have
you had to say something to somebody
have you ever said like whoa enough yeah
definitely I mean yeah for sure
and I ate also you know I think this
time is making me feel braver and more
vocal and I think I'm you know glow has
sort of been this like perfectly timed
kind of bravery training camp for me
feminist wise and creatively that I
realized that I've wasted so many jobs
feeling scared and silent and like I was
gonna get fired if I I didn't sort of
silently accept the weird flirtations
that were happening and you know it made
me be like oh I'm scared to do that
weird choice that I was gonna do in this
scene because I guess my job is to be
like quiet hot girl for this part and
not like the crazy character that I
wanted to sort of play and I realized I
was getting in my own way with that so
now I try to walk into onto sets
setting a precedent of like you know I'm
I'm here to do my job and so I'm gonna
do the weird choice on the first take
and just get weirder and weirder from
there does the physicality help that on
glow the fact that yeah you guys are all
doing stunts and fighting and yes
totally yes on like yeah in other jobs I
exercised but like it was all for the
beach like I would think of wide-shots
as like okay I'm Betty sucking it and
being here in my tiny costume and then I
can act when it's the close-up and you
know in glow my whole body is being
required to do powerful functional
things instead of like Posie Barbie
things and that has been so freeing and
empowering and you know makes me feel
like the character from head to toe
instead of like character from head to
collarbone and Betty from collarbone to
toes right that makes sense because
you're acting with your whole body
yeah what did you do in ghost I'm sorry
a ghost town did your basement was the
pottery wheel I love that movie I love
you Ray I love that I love that I cried
on a plane I had to turn that I was
crying on a plane watching that so hard
I had to [ __ ] turn up on my
sunglasses like a psychopath jim has
happens when you're on a plane cuz you
are more emotional watching things cuz
you're above your whole life and away
from everyone you love you're probably
connected earphones monitors yeah Jim's
also got severe emotional distress yes
literally I'll never forget that just
week sunglasses rule but I was watching
that movie I was the world war two nurse
ghosts I think I had too long okay I
don't know it's probably the part you
cry the hardest so it's probably the
part that you were most affected by
remember that member yeah no I think you
remember that do the nurse handle this
anymore it's too much emotion no but I
remember that movie made me cry weird
things made me cry and that movie made
me cry I never I never actually finished
the movie I got the 80% through and
there was one reveal and I was just a
blubbering ass it was enough something
about the woman Gervase realized that
somebody had been dead the whole time or
that was her husband who had been I
don't remember what it was but he
realized something about the woman in
the movie and I was like oh I made you
cry blubber cry no just leaking out of
my demise and right charming yeah I
remember that I should watch that movie
again
do you so we were talking to mark and he
was talking about how there's more
wrestling in this season yeah
is that kind of was that a scary thing
for you guys in the sense that like yeah
I mean I I definitely do them I would
say the most wrestling this season mark
doesn't just [ __ ] no more he does have
the easiest gig doesn't he a hundred
percent right yeah I'm slamming my neck
into the ground and then they're like
mark we're gonna catch a piece of used
to just really ride no but I I yeah I
wrestle a bunch this season I get to
wrestle Kea Stevens who's the girl in
our cast was an actual pro wrestler
among other people I get to wrestle they
won't spoil but it's wrestling a pro
wrestler is the funnest thing ever
cuz she just puts you exact it feels
like swimming like you'd think it'd be
more painful but she just puts you
exactly where you need to be and throws
you and makes you look like you're the
most powerful strongest but
no not to hurt you like you're probably
more likely to get hurt by another
active wrestler knows exactly how to
throw you how to pick you up I mean
that's unique thing about wrestling is
not only does she know how to not hurt
you but she knows what to do with her
body so it looks like I'm kicking the
[ __ ] yes definitely
yeah and although I you know when I
wrestle a libri you know because I'm
bigger than her I do most of the like
throwing moves and power moves and I
sort of decide when a move is happening
because I'm sort of the base but
wrestling kiya she's so much stronger
than me and so that was the first time I
got like tossed around like a rag doll
we fight in episode 4 and she treated me
like I had no bones it was have you
gotten hurt uh yeah I have it's um it's
not safe but yeah it just feels
basically like a hundred fender benders
in a row like the the adrenaline when
you're doing it even though the crowd is
being paid to cheer they're still
cheering you you feel like you could
lift a car and then the next day you're
like oh that hurts so much all of it is
it just the bumps and bruises no actual
like injury injuries I mean I definitely
got my bell rung a couple times yes
stood up and saw stars for sure but then
the ham gene comes in it's like don't
stop performing but yeah it's not it's
like playing you know a tiny football
game like you're ramming your head into
things and people are jumping on you and
there are definitely moments where moves
happen you're like I'm either gonna try
and get up and every bone in my body is
broken or I'm totally fine and so far
not good I've been totally what people
watching - like you should even though
they're extras they're paid you still
have people watching you so you don't
want that you don't want it you don't
want to look like you don't know what
you're doing or like you're ease like oh
yeah [ __ ] snowflake you want to look
like yes exactly
yeah yeah I know the ego comes in and
pride and yeah I never understood it I
never understood sports or anything I
and certainly never understood wrestling
but I have such respect for it now I
know you're a wrestling fan I am yes
he's a little wagon fan though he's a
hulkamaniac
I do I just jump onto whatever's popular
so yes you didn't want any growing up my
I grew up in a house of boys my brothers
loved football my dad loved it and I
just never was like I just I felt so
cringy watching it and I I you know my
least favorite part was when like the
retired football players would be
commentators and be like well in my day
did and I thought that's how being
coached by wrestlers would be sort of
that their ego and pride coming into it
but wrestling there's so much
vulnerability and ego swallowing that
goes into it
at the start so they're the kindest most
wonderful giving people like your job as
a wrestler is to be vulnerable there's
nothing more vulnerable than to stand in
a glitter diaper and fight for justice
and then like you know when someone
touches you you have to act like they're
the most powerful person to ever touch
you so it's not there's no ego in it
whatsoever no and you're completely
trusting somebody else with your body
yes it could kill you you just have to
trust that they're gonna be professional
it's so funny when people first start to
wrap their head around what wrestling
actually is because you're like
everybody thinks this is fake why why
don't you do this much faker like this
hurts way too much yeah yeah the first
time I took a back bump which is when
you land on your back I was like oh I
did it way wrong that hurt a lot and
Chavo Guerrero jr. was like no no you
did it it's going to hurt every time
once you heard that it was the outcome
was predetermined all right you forget
that oh yeah this does hurt you're still
being thrown off a top rope yes you
slammed on the ground under plywood with
canvas wrapped over it yeah right yes
yes no someone safe and even though it's
predetermined it's still it's a ton of
improv absolutely we don't do improv we
we choreograph every second because
they're afraid of breaking the actresses
but in pro wrestling it's they're
whispering to each I mean I don't want
to talk do you go to actual like like
all these wrestling matches and into
real ones now we have been to we went to
a smack
in LA and we saw a real thing happen
where a guy did you see this I'm sure I
forget the IRA who the Irish do oh yeah
Sheamus and Cesaro yes yes one of them
oh my god I'm just teeth into a
turnbuckle and pushed his two front
teeth up into his gum
did you really happened and so and
here's he gets slam he hits the post he
goes mouth first his two front teeth go
up into his gums I think it crammed up
there and he finishes the match like
that it's just blood coming out of his
mouth he finishes the match and then he
comes back and like I was back there for
the X I think I was working I was
hosting the pre-show for that show oh
wow and and he's just walking around
like you kind of smiling I was like are
you are you all right that looked brutal
man he's like aw thanks it was one of
the sexiest things I've ever seen
yeah for sure they have to take like
like pliers and pull like it doctors
doctors of course have to do it
yeah his teeth down and then he had to
like wear braces for a while and and
everything everything's fine now yeah we
felt so inside baseball it was the whole
goal cast sitting in the front row we
were like oh wow what a great guy I
wonder where they had the blood and then
he walked over when no cameras were on
him and he came close to us to like
check his mouth and blood poured from
his marrow for like that is literally as
real as yeah cuz I mean I didn't even
know teeth could do that no yeah that's
getting knocked out though and having to
to [ __ ] miss colored fake ones put it
right and this yeah this is this is
wrestling that's exactly what it was
they were like they were like oh my god
I think his two front teeth got knocked
out and once they figured out what it
was they're like oh no no no they just
got knocked up there we can just pull
them back they go like would you say it
looked like they were gone oh there's a
lot I would even hurt when they pulled
him down and must have hurt yes a little
bit don't look like they hurt but they
do feel good
put that on a pillow you bet it is